there are some moments in life you never
[Applause]
forget the Depression hit everyone hard
no jobs no food we were broke looks like
you still owe a balance on this
semester so what's that about making
some money you're the rowing team you
you get a part-time job included she
place to live Amman crew is the most
difficult team sport in the
world the average human body is just not
meant for such
things most of you will not be chosen
beautiful speech
coach they're announcing the team today
are you going to make it we rode out of
need come on boys the need to stay in
school we need to eat to sleep we got to
keep these right long as we stay on the
team Washington Huskies coach is
bringing an inexperienced vote to
competition they said we couldn't
compete with the richest school for the
nation the Washington boat is taking the
lead Washington has done it I got 9
seconds under the course record Olympic
GE this year Olympic GE I didn't realize
that bunch of kids load like no one else
that's ever come through here everybody
else tires they just get stronger we
have a boat that I believe could qualify
for an Olympic spot if you know what
you're
doing they said we couldn't beat the
Germans we got to beat those other
schools first but coach says we had a
shot maybe we can roll as a team if you
guys don't get yourselves figured out
you're not racing at all boys that
boat Tiger but they didn't understand
who we were the show was in this
book I don't believe what I'm
[Applause]
seeing best B
connect sweat and
pain what is worth I'm I'm proud of you
boys inspiring well you missed a part
where I told him not to tip over and I
won Ro for your
country Ro for each other for all the
people who never believed in you as one
as
[Music]
one